I'm done with it I would current you
following the science though natural
immunity is stronger what if natural
immunity actually prevented reinfection
with variant more than the vaccine would
you think that the government should
take that into account so let's say it
is true because it is do you think that
then the government should take that
into account when doing the mandates if
they can consistently prove that someone
has full immunity then it would be
different conversation but that's just
not how how many people have had Co
twice versus people who had it after
being
vaccinated almost not but obviously we
know there's a big problem with the
vaccines people still getting it so this
is kind of a totality we're just saying
when we balance people's freedoms versus
the vaccine you think it should be a
mandate across the board I'm done with
this I would encourage you following the
science though natural immunity is
stronger natural
immunity yeah it's stronger against all
variants the vaccine isn't just read up
on the science go to CDC literally
everything she said was the opposite of
the truth